well can i start tonight
by firstly acknowledging the gadigal
people their elders past and present and
emerging
can i also has has been
my custom ever since i became prime
minister
to acknowledge any members of our
defence forces who are here tonight
and our veterans
and to say thank you
for the country
that you fought for and you've given to
us you've gifted to us and for the
freedom that we enjoy here today
it's a difficult night for liberals and
nationals around the country as nights
like this always are
they are humbling
but so is victory victory is also
humbling and always should be
tonight i've spoken to the leader of the
opposition and the incoming prime
minister anthony albanese and i've
congratulated him on his election
victory this evening
in this country
at a time like this
when we look around the world
and particularly when we see those in
the ukraine
fighting for their very freedom and
liberty
i think on a light night like tonight we
can reflect on the greatness of our
democracy
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you
and so on a night like tonight it is
proper to acknowledge the functioning of
our democracy
i've always believed in australians
and their judgment and i've always been
prepared to accept their verdicts and
tonight they have delivered their
verdict and i congratulate anthony
albanese in the labor party and i wish
him and his government all the very best
now there are many votes still to count
that is true
and there are many pre-polls and postals
that will still come in
but i believe it's very important that
this country has certainty
i think it's very important this country
can move forward and particularly over
the course of this week with the
important meetings that are being held
in tokyo i think it's vitally important
that there's a very clear understanding
about the government of this country
this has been a time of great upheaval
over these past few years
and it has imposed a heavy price on our
country and on all australians and i
think all australians have felt that
deeply
and we've seen in our own politics a
great deal of disruption
as the way people have voted today with
major parties having one of the lowest
primary rights that we've ever seen
that says a lot i think about the
upheaval that is taking place in our
nation and i think it is important for
our nation to heal and to move forward
but at the same time
three years ago i stood before you
and i said i believed in miracles
i still believe in miracles
[Music]
i still believe in miracles as i always
have
and the biggest miracles as i said three
years ago were standing beside me and
here they are again tonight with jenny
and abby and lily
[Applause]
they are the greatest miracle in my life
thank you
thank you
but there's another great miracle thank
you there's another great miracle which
i want to give thanks for tonight
and that is the miracle of the
australian people
what australians have endured over these
past few years has shown a tremendous
depth of character and resilience and
strength
and each and every day i've had the
great privilege to lead this nation over
the last more than three and a half
years and the one thing i have always
counted on has been the strength and
resilience and character of the
australian people
it has been the australian people under
the strong support of a strong
government that has enabled all of us to
come through to where we are today and i
think that's something that all
australians can give thanks for as we
move forward